what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU and of course like
I always mention Spider-Man however this
time we are talking about Tom Holland
Spider-Man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe while it does seem like Sony
over in the spider-verse on there and
does kind of seem like they are coming
up with a plan and that plan might
actually be pretty dang good if they go
through with it of course we're all
still waiting to figure out what is
happening with Spider-Man 4. the next
Tom Holland movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the last time that we
left Tom Holland at the end of
Spider-Man no way home nobody remembered
who Peter Parker was keep in mind people
do remember who Spider-Man was but they
do not remember that Spider-Man is Peter
Parker and I say that kind of loosely
since Wong and Doctor Strange have
mentioned that and Wong mentioned it
again in She-Hulk there is a chance that
Wong perhaps knows that Peter Parker is
Spider-Man but we'll deal with that in
the next Spider-Man film in which today
it does seem like we may have a little
bit of details on on including a report
on the release date for Spider-Man 4.
now if you haven't been keeping up to
date with the Spider-Man news or you're
new to the channel a reminder that Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
and Amy Pascal a Sony executive producer
did confirm that they have already begun
working on Spider-Man 4. they said this
about a week after Spider-Man no way
home came out and they said that they
told us that so we wouldn't have to
worry about Spider-Man no longer being
in the MCU he is staying in the MCU and
they are making another Spider-Man film
so it's happening Spider-Man 4 is
happening we know that and today it
looks like we have some details on it
this is coming from
thecosmiccircus.com and they have been
right about Scoops in the past today
they released an article about reports
about Spider-Man 4 again including the
release date and some details about what
the plot could be and how it could
actually tie into the Daredevil series
now obviously this is super exciting
fans have been waiting for it Daredevil
and Spider-Man to interact with each
other for a very very long time and I'm
not talking about Matt Murdock
interacting with Peter Parker I'm
talking about Daredevil interacting and
fighting with Spider-Man so let's dive
into this report it says Peter Parker
Tom Holland when we lost saw Tom
Holland's Peter Parker everyone he had
ever loved was either gone or had their
mind erased by Doctor Strange to save
the Multiverse from complete upheaval so
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe Peter
Parker never existed but Spider-Man
lives on and here's a big part they say
how do we pick up Peter's story from
here well we first have to see where
Peter Parker will reappear within the
MCU timeline from what we are being told
his next MCU appearance will be sooner
rather than later according to one of
our sources Spider-Man's next solo MCU
Adventure will premiere on July 12th of
2024. now let's talk about this before
we continue on with the report this is
actually really great I did expect us to
get the Spider-Man film before Avengers
the King Dynasty and Secret Wars because
they obviously have to address the fact
that nobody knows who Peter Parker is
right now they have to either
reintroduce him to certain characters
and the Avengers or somehow get certain
people to remember exactly who he was
otherwise he won't really be able to
interact with the Avengers at least not
in a way that he used to now this does
kind of put Spider-man right next to
other projects and the cosmic circus
actually addresses this they say this
would play Spider-Man 4 near the end of
phase 5. additionally it will release
just two weeks prior to the release of
another MCU film The Thunderbolts it is
expected for Marvel to work out their
upcoming MCU schedule as there are
likely to be a number of shifts in The
Phase 5 timeline now that actually kind
of happened today Marvel delayed four
MCU projects however there will more
than likely be other shifts as well if
you're not aware today Marvel Studios
delayed blade Deadpool 3 The Fantastic
Four and Avengers Secret Wars Avengers
the King Dynasty remains to be unchanged
now some of these were only moved a
couple of months like Deadpool 3 but
some were moved as far as seven months
away like the Fantastic Four and with
this will most likely come more changes
which I'm assuming they'll do to fit
Spider-Man around phase five and not be
too crammed next to another movie after
all Marvel Studios and Sony know the
power of Spider-Man in the MCU and they
know that pretty much if they release
Spider-Man near another movie that movie
will most likely get overshadowed unless
it was an Avengers film or a huge film
like that but I don't think so I think
the Thunderbolts might get a little
overshadowed if Spider-Man was released
just two weeks before so they'll most
likely move this around now the report
continues to say now what story could
the upcoming installment of Spider-Man
tell for Spider-Man 4 the story will
more likely than not have our hero
handle a street level scenario before
rising to the challenge of an Avengers
level threat this street level story
where being told may actually handle the
aftermath of Daredevil born again how
the Disney Plus show will play a role in
the upcoming film remains to be seen so
Daredevil is going to be heading back to
New York after She-Hulk back in Hell's
Kitchen messing some stuff up fighting
with some bad guys causing some problems
and making a mess that it looks like
Spider-Man might have to help clean up
now I think of Kingpin when I think
about this Kingpin is obviously going to
be the villain of Daredevil but he's
also a very very huge Spider-Man villain
and I think it's only a matter of time
until we finally see Spider-Man go up
against Kingpin and Kingpin is kind of
seeming like he's a big bad of the
street level right now he was in Hawkeye
we know that he's going to be in the
Echo series and we know he's going to be
the villain of the Daredevil series he's
appearing a lot so it would make sense
that he would appear in Spider-Man 4 as
well especially if Spider-Man is going
to be tackling the street level and
cleaning up after Daredevil and this
would also be really cool because this
would mean that Spider-Man and Daredevil
could team up on the big screen and I
personally think that would be an
amazing Spider-Man movie Spider-Man
teaming up with Daredevil to go up
against Kingpin I think fans would
really really enjoy that but I know a
lot of people are asking well what about
the Symbiote the post-credits scene for
Spider-Man no way home set up the Venom
symbiote in the MCU is he not going to
be getting that in this film well
according to this report from the cosmic
circus it doesn't look like it and the
reason for that is because Marvel
Studios might want to go the comic
accurate route giving Spider-Man the
symbiote suit in Avengers Secret Wars
which actually happens in the comics for
the very first time
they continue to say this would mean
that while the Symbiote will be
introduced during phase six of the MCU
Peter Parker may not have his own solo
outing in the suit until phase seven
after the Multiverse Saga has ended and
I'm not totally against this idea I
think it would be really cool to give
him the suit in one of the upcoming
Avengers films give him a little bit
more power against King the Conqueror
and whoever is going to be the main
villain of Secret Wars I'm thanking Dr
Doom but we'll see and then just have
him keep the suit after and have him
deal with the repercussions of the suit
slash symbiote in the next Spider-Man
film Spider-Man 5. I'm assuming we are
going to get another trilogy but of
course we'll have to wait and see on
that but this could set up some really
good Spider-Man appearances in the MCU
the next one being Spider-Man 4 which
according to the cosmic circus will be
on July 12th of 2024 could involve
Daredevil and could show Spider-Man
going up against Kingpin then of course
we'll see him in the Avengers films and
hopefully we'll pick up with Spider-Man
5 where he gets the symbiote suit and
has to deal with it that's a pretty
exciting course for Spider-Man and the
MCU over the next few years one that I
can definitely get on board with and
hopefully this release date is accurate
and we don't have to wait that much
longer to actually get the Spider-Man 4
movie and if this is true I would expect
an announcement for Spider-Man 4
relatively soon this release date puts
it at about a year and a half away which
means they'll have to start production
on it relatively soon which means some
things are going to start to get out so
Marvel Studios will most likely announce
this soon if this is the release date
but let me know what you think about all
of this in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
MCU for live updates you can follow me
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof